antoine merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors dans une conférence
en ligne avec des étudiants de
l'institut des relations internationales
de moscou sergueï lavrov a donc évoqué
pendant près de deux heures de très
nombreux sujets que peut-on retenir de
cette conférence oui le ministre russe
des affaires étrangères a abordé de
nombreux dossiers en particulier à la
lumière de cette crise sanitaire que le
monde entier est en train de traverser
là par exemple parler de
multilatéralisme en réagissant à la
déclaration de son homologue français
jean yves le drian qui disait craindre
la semaine dernière que le monde d'après
soit pire que le monde d'avant je vous
propose d'écouter sa réponse destot ps
pour lés j'espère que la crise aura une
influence positive sur les relations
entre les pays de l'est ils nient viser
autre chose que je n'ai pas entendu
cette citation de jean yves le drian vu
que je sais ce qu'il donne beaucoup
d'interviews ces derniers temps
notamment sur le nouveau concept de
futilité rationalisme non à choctaw je
te mieux poche le canda l'idée selon
laquelle le monde après la pandémie sera
pire tu laisses aujourd'hui ce genre de
prévisions existent elles se reflètent
en partie dans les aciers qu'on a déjà
mentionné aujourd'hui notamment le
rapport entre les niveaux national et
supranational la tentation de se
renfermer sur soi neige de s'isoler
normal ce n'est qu'une illusion on ne
réussira pas faire ou utilisent le
comprenons que les x celle où l'on
observera ses tendances chez certains
hommes politiques ils lanceront ce genre
d'appel lors de campagnes électorales
dans leur pays plus beaucoup d'autres
switcher odieux bogdanov il a ensuite
poursuivi son raisonnement est observé
que les pays qui prétendent soutenir le
multilatéralisme ont bien souvent du mal
à traduire leurs belles paroles en actes
écoutez liée selon votre colonne
australienne
cette approche pessimiste que vous avez
pigé selon laquelle il y aurait une
péjoration de la coopération dans le
cadre suisse
elle est formulée en france tu as cool
un pays il ya de la force dans nos
stations sismiques sur la seule chose
très positive si positive j'ai déjà dit
que depuis deux ans la france l
allemagne promeuvent le concept de
multilatéralisme
elles se sont prononcés pour la création
d'une alliance des défenseurs du
multilatéralisme
c'est à dire la proche multilatéralisme
j'ai déjà posé cette question mais n'ai
reçu aucune réponse aujourd'hui pour
voir la france l'allemagne et ceux qui
se sont jointes à elles sur cette voie
considère tiges que le multilatéralisme
et quelque chose d'autre que les nations
unies
à ce titre il a rappelé l'importance des
activités des différentes agences qui
dépendent de l'onu est qualifiée de
contreproductive les récentes critiques
à l'encontre de l'une d'elles
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
sur un tout autre sujet sergey lavrov a
déploré le peu d'avancée significative
de la part de kiev concernant le conflit
dans l'est de l'ukraine
raison pour laquelle selon lui le sommet
au format normandie prévu pour ce mois
d'avril n'a pas pu se tenir
il sera malgré tout de nouveaux question
d'ukraine en fin de semaine pour le
ministre russe à l'occasion d'une
visioconférence avec ses homologues
français allemands et ukrainiens
une réunion qui n'aborde par l'aura
compris avec beaucoup d'optimisme
merci beaucoup antoine pour toutes ces
précisions autres claireaux en direct de
moscou